c'est cette surcharge hospitalière qui
motive tout le discours politique
donc oui moi je ne souhaite pas qu'ils
aient plus de malades en réanimation
mais il n'y a pas de catastrophe il n'y
a pas de catastrophe et il n'y a pas une
un nombre de malades un accueil malades
vous savez de nos services d'urgence
aujourd'hui ne sont pas débordés
nous avons un nombre de malades qui
arrivent régulièrement et ce qui nous
gêne c'est effectivement les places
derrière avec les conséquences que ça va
avoir sur les malades qui n'ont pas la
cote vide et qui sont majoritaires c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui en ile de france
nous nous sommes en train de
déprogrammer quasiment 50% de l'activité
et on risque de monter un petit peu plus
c'est à dire qu'on va avoir des retards
à la prise en charge d'un certain nombre
de pathologies
les deux premières causes de mentalité
ce sont les cancers et les maladies
cardiovasculaires on nous avons des
retards de prise en charge sur ces
patients qui vont avoir des conséquences
en terme de de ce qu'on appelle nous la
morbi-mortalité crc des morts évitables
supplémentaires donc il faut discuter
tout ça c'est à dire que quand on est en
guerre il faut se donner les moyens
or on ne s'est pas donné les moyens nous
n'avons pas produit les armes et dont
les armes
et bien il y avait armé l'hôpital il y
avait assuré à partir du moment où on
savait qu'on allait avoir des vaccins ce
qui est quand même très positif on
n'imaginait pas il ya un an que nous
allons des vaccins aussi rapidement sauf
que maintenant il va falloir produire
massivement ces vaccins et le débat
qu'il ya aujourd'hui c'est il faut
exiger la levée les brevets et la
réquisition des entreprises
moi je suis scandalisé que l'europe et
la france est encore voté contre lors
d'une heure et une récente réunion de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
contre la proposition de l'afrique du
sud est de l'inde sur la lauze et
l'hébreu vestiaire qu'on aujourd'hui on
privilégie le business des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques contre contre la santé
mondiale et ça c'est un véritable
problème on ne peut pas continuer à être
comme ça à la merci des laboratoires oui
bien sûr que les états unis comme
d'habitude on chez eux les entreprises
qui vont bien pour produire les vaccins
mais il ya que les états unis et le
reste du monde aujourd'hui est à
l'abandon
en ce qui concerne l'approvisionnement
et la capacité à pouvoir s
mais massivement
[Musique]